you're right or something
oh no thanks
you okay
yeah i'm good
you don't look good
i mean
you look like you just saw
what you just saw
it looks like he was dying don't you
think
yeah
he did
but the ambulance got me really fast so
who knows
i should probably go
nate um
yeah
i'm really sorry about your mom
i should have called i
i wanted to i just
wasn't exactly meeting by the thumb
oh of course not
i'm i'm sorry i guess it's a weird time
to bring it up no it's okay
i got
it death makes you think of death
so you two think he's dead
i don't know bro
it was pretty [ __ ]
let me try me out
ah
will you go slow
it's more fun if i go fast
yeah
i'll go slow
you're gonna want to hold on tighter
than that
so um
what are we talking about
i i didn't have like a thing i just
i thought it was kind of nice talking
again yesterday i guess it'd been a
while huh
so uh
you want to know what i've been up to
for the past uh seven years oh i've
followed along and about that
yeah that's one version of it
sorry i was just kidding
too soon
still into lady rockers huh
still
how do you even fifth grade piano
recital you played that uh florence in
the machine song while everyone else is
playing fairy giaca and [ __ ]
wow
you actually remember that it was cool
unexpected
i think one of you took simon's laptop
if you did we're gonna find out
and soon
i'm sure you had a perfectly good reason
for taking it but you gotta tell me now
because if we find it and we find you've
been hiding it and lying about it
especially after i've given you a chance
to come clean i don't have to tell you
how that's going to sound to a judge
right
you guys have to say
[Music]
yes um
why are we even talking about the laptop
when you just found peanut oil in audi's
soccer it's moisturizing
and you know some of us actually like to
spend money on makeup once in a while
i'm trying to help you guys here
this is serious
why do you think i'm sitting here
instead of officer miller
i'm a homicide detective
you're not that bad
you saved me for myself yesterday
you may even be a good guy
deep inside
very deep inside
even when you're always late hey for the
record
i did make an effort to be on time first
date
this wasn't meant to be i guess
i can't talk here or anywhere yeah about
that
this is the phone that i i've been using
one for work long before and even put
one in your bag
i just thought if you
ever wanted to talk
my number's in there
aren't we in enough trouble to disney
we can't do anything until tomorrow and
if i could sleep maybe i could see
things a little bit more clearly but
then my brain it's just playing
ping-pong with itself i actually have a
trick for that i don't want drugs ha
no when i can't stop thinking about
something i don't want to think about i
watch horror movies
and that makes you feel better totally i
mean when you're bracing for the next
jump scare you don't have time to think
about anything else
that actually makes sense
so
have you seen the birds
no
what okay we need to fix that right now
are you gonna watch with me
yeah i mean you kind of got my head
spinning too rojas
i'm gonna send you the link
you ready
okay
three
two
one
[Applause]
okay new turn it off you want to come
over
we could watch it together and bonus
you can meet my lizard
excuse me
uh that that wasn't a lie i actually
have a bearded dragon named stan
thank god
oh he's really cute
i'll tell him you said so
nate
are you sure we shouldn't skip this
meeting
maybe we should bring the laptop to the
police can i point out the movie was
working
we turned it off two seconds ago and
you're already worried again we are
about to meet a potential murderer in
the middle of the night
i just want to see what he has to say
there's usually more to a story than
meets eye
good riddance
did we really just do that
yeah
we did
holy [ __ ]
thanks for trusting me
who said i trust you you talked to
cooper with me
and now you are standing on the edge of
the cliff with me
a suspected murderer
you're standing on the edge of a cliff
with me also a suspected murderer
maybe we're both idiots
brown road
i
solemnly swear not to murder you today
or
any day in the future
you are ridiculous you know that it
concerns me that you're avoiding a
promise not to murder
nate mccauley
i promise not to murder you
[Music]
you okay
yeah
we should we should get out of here
i'm sorry i lied to you okay
but i'm not sorry you didn't know the
truth
because that would mean you'd know about
her mental health issues her drug
problems how she abandoned me
i told the lie because it was easier
than the truth then once you say
something like that
how do you one say it
you sound like a [ __ ] psycho at that
point
and that's not how i wanted you to look
at me
[ __ ]
my 15 upstairs getting coffee over
[Music]
yeah hey jim we need you downstairs damn
it copy that on my way
[Music]
you have a long lonely ride in mexico
ahead of you
we should get moving
look maybe addy's right and we can solve
this before i take off
i'm just not holding my breath
if you don't believe in this crazy plan
then why are you even here
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
please please tell me you've seen me
[Music]
ah
nate
we're gonna get who did this
we're gonna figure this out you don't
have to leave
for a debate team captain
i'm not sold ross
okay
well i don't want this to be the last
time we dance and i know it's not fair
for me to ask but if i don't i'm gonna
regret it for the rest of my life
will you stay
for me
[Music]
someone like
[Music]
we got so lucky he didn't see us you did
not need to come here stop trying to
protect you don't try to save me why are
you risking your [ __ ] future for me
brahma because
i want to be with you
not just because we're thrown into this
weird situation together and i think
you're hot
although i do
but you're also smart and you're funny
and you do the right thing more often
than you give yourself credit for and
i like that you never sugarcoat anything
in
in your horrible taste in movies and the
fact that you have an actual lizard
and i can't go more than a few minutes
without wanting to kiss you so
there's that
it was more of a rhetorical question you
know
[Music]
[Music]
boys